the 80 year old senator is said to be
recovering amazingly well from Friday's
surgery doctors say that blood clot was
removed from above McCain's left eye
tests reveal determine was associated
with the blood clot glioblastoma account
for about 15% of all primary brain
tumors the average patient survives
about 15 months our chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook is with us
good morning when Charlie tell us about
this particular cancer and the treatment
options well as you mentioned it's a
very deadly type of brain cancer and the
statistics in the past have been have
been grim however there are some new
treatments there is a standard first
line which involves chemotherapy and
radiation as Nancy said the chemotherapy
is a is a pill usually called
temozolomide
taken by mouth and generally tolerated
pretty well and in treatment options
other than that well that's the first
line there are a bunch of other things
in development remember that Scott
Pelley did a piece on 60 minutes with
Henry Freedman down at Duke where they
injected poliovirus 2 into a tumor to
get some immune reaction to that there's
even an electrical cap that people put
on to try to create disrupting
electrical fields and there are
immunotherapies because one of the
things that cancer does which makes it
so deadly is that it hides itself from
your immune system it cloaks itself so a
lot of these new therapies are to strip
that cloak away and say oh there it is
I'm gonna go out and kill you
killing the thing about glioblastoma is
that it creates these finger-like
projections through the brain and that's
what makes it difficult to treat right
that's exactly right so you know at that
they say in the statement that they were
able to remove by imaging studies at
least anything that was visible the
problem with glioblastoma is by the time
it's they're almost always there a tiny
little microscopic foci that have spread
elsewhere which is why you always need
some other treatment he has been treated
three times I believe for malignant
melanoma but it was stage zero and non
invasive could this be related I don't
think it is related in fact you know a
few days ago on Friday when they said
well we're sending the cloud off the
pathology but we're gonna wait on our
treatment options to look at the
pathology I thought well it's a benign
little blood clot why I mean little
blood clot but if it's benign clot why
wait for that pathology report I
thinking it could be malignant melanoma
that had metastasized to the brain so
did some neurologists I spoke to so I
was surprised to find out it's yet a
different type of tumor it's a primary
brain tumor meaning it hasn't spread
from somewhere else to the brain it
started in the brain but let me
understand there probably were not
looking for this when they went in they
were really trying to find out what was
behind the blood clot yeah I think they
he came and we don't know a lot of
details about the symptoms he said it
was routine they did a scan they saw
this clot there and they said let's go
in and find out what it is now what's
interesting is remember that during the
testimony with James Comey there was a
moment or two where he sort of had some
confusion some difficulty getting words
out and you think about the frontal lobe
where that clot is and where the tumor
is the front of the brain is where
you're in which is involved with
communication language so you can
imagine that if there's a problem there
that could have given him the simulaid
Graham said he'd been feeling tired
recently dude yeah that is one of the
symptoms along with anything any part of
the brain that's affected it can affect
it cause a headache it can cause a
weakness it can cause little tiny
seizures there are all sorts of problems
thanks but I'll tell you something he's
a strong guy and I'm sure he's gonna be
putting up his dukes yeah he is a
fighter and I said this online faith of
my father's is still one of the greatest
books and really details one of the
toughest fights he he fought already as
a powa and worthy of another read dr.
Jon LaPook thank you thank you